Okay.
Well,
we've seen now how the early tutors managed to reestablish the authority of the
monarchy,
how that achievement was threatened by the succession crisis,
which was looming under Henry the eighth.
How that problem was met by actions,
which further extended royal authority over the church.
But at the same time of course introduced a new form of instability into the
kingdom,
um,
potential conflict over religion.
Um,
but that wasn't all that was going on.
And there are other sources of instability which was set in motion at around the
same time in the second quarter of the 16th century.
Um,
what adds additional complexity to the whole situation is the fact that there
was simultaneous shifts in some of the basic aspects of economic and social
life,
which in 1500 would have been more or less taken for granted.
The problem then had been political instability,
not social instability,
but soon social instability was to be on the agenda.
And people knew by the 1530s and 1540s that they lived in radically changing
times,
uh,
in more ways than one.
The phenomenon of which they were most acutely aware was rising prices,
rising prices for the basic necessities of life.
Prices of goods had been fairly stable for most of the 15th and early 16th
centuries,
but around about the second decade of the 16th century,
they began rising.
If you look at your handout section one you'll find there an index of prices for
what's described as a basket of basic consumables,
mostly food stuffs and other essentials of life.
I can see from that index,
which stands at around 100 in 1500 how prices rose rapidly in the course of the
16th century.
At first it was a modest trend.
It picked up momentum in the 1530s price rises.
We're very rapid indeed in 1540s and fifties and they continued to rise more
slowly thereafter,
so they faced a problem of inflation and the causes of that inflation,
um,
we're complex,
they're much debated.
But amongst the,
one of the most principals seems to have been the fact that population was also
growing.
The pressure was being felt of increasing numbers of people on relatively
inelastic resources,
forcing up prices.
If you look at section two of your handout,
you'll see the best figures available from historians of what the population of
England was at different points in the earlier 16th century.
Best estimates,
we have suggested in 1520s about 2.4 million
by the 1550s that had risen to about 3 million by 1573 point 3 million and still
rising.
The annual rate of increase can be calculated and it's there on the right hand
side in the 1540 is about 0.64% per annum,
1560s almost 1% per annum,
1570s over 1% per annum.
These are quite rapid rates have increase for a preindustrial population.
In fact,
that kind of rate of population increase was not matched again in England until
the late 18th century at the height of the industrial revolution.
So the population was rising now explaining why that was.
So it's far from easy,
uh,
but in all likelihood it was to do with a fall in death rates in the early 16th
century in a population which had a fairly high fertility rate and a high
propensity to grow.
If it wasn't cold by severe mortality,
so death rate's still high by our standards seem to have been falling somewhat.
If you're interested in that kind of historical demography and we'd like to
pursue the issue of population dynamics,
then I'd be happy to advise you on more detailed reading,
but for the moment it's enough to just register the essential facts.
Prices are rising,
population is rising,
the two are probably connected.
What I want to focus on today is the fallout from all of that,
some of the stressors in society which were produced by this dynamic of
population growth and price inflation,
how it impacted on different groups in society
and one can start at the top with the landlords.
Gentlemen,
no woman,
the monarchy
in most cases,
the bulk of landlords in comes as you know,
came from the rents and they needed that income to sustain the lifestyles which
were appropriate to their station as gentlemen to sustain their magnificence in
that situation.
Their biggest problem as a 16th century went on was rising prices,
but an inflexible income
at worst.
Many of them had tenants who enjoyed fixed rents.
They'd been granted fixed rents at some point in the past.
At best,
they were in a position to periodically modify the rents they got for their
lands,
but they were still relatively inflexible.
Land was often granted for long periods of time on a fixed agreement for that
term.
It might be 2030 years.
Land was also let,
according to the customs as you know,
which had been established in particular areas,
which might inhibit the landlord's capacity to adjust the rent levels.
That's very bad news when prices are rising.
So how did these people cope?
For the most part,
landlords coped by gradually trying to alter the terms on which they granted
their land to the peasantry.
They tried to let it for shorter leases,
which they could renegotiate more often,
try to get the lease down to seven years,
10 years or whatever rather than 90,
which had been quite common in the past.
They also tried to change local customs regarding what kind of fine or down
payment they could get when they let land.
For example,
on the estates of the Herbert family,
uh,
which were located in wheelchair in the southwest.
In the first half of the 16th century,
they manage to roughly double the fines which they were getting when a new
tenant took land from them.
Well,
it was only possible for landlords to squeeze their tenants a little harder in
that way because land was in demand.
The rising population rising population for the first time in a century and a
half meant that there was demand for land in a way that hadn't really been known
since the 14th century.
There's a lot of evidence of people nibbling at wasteland forest land,
more land,
bringing land into cultivation in the forest of Inglewood,
for example,
which is located up in the northwest of England up here,
there was a survey made of illegal encroachments in the forest.
People cutting out a little piece of land for themselves where they could squat.
Ah,
and it revealed that over a period of 20 or 30 years,
almost 200 encroachments had been made into the forest there.
So pressure on the land and inevitably also has the population rose these size
of the holy landless population.
Rose too.
There were more young people survive into adulthood for whom there was no
inheritance,
no place on the land.
Although shifting circumstances,
the pressure's on landlords,
the pressures that they pass on to their tenants.
The pressure of population growth help to explain the emergence in the early
16th century of some quite severe tensions in the relationships between
landlords and farm tenants.
Tensions in particular over customs
and the emergence of one particular cardinal grievance.
The grievance of enclosure,
not as I've explained earlier in some areas of the kingdom,
agriculture had never been practiced in great open fields,
but had been practiced already on end closed farms
before 1500 in the areas where there was,
there were open fields.
Some of them had been reorganized by enclosing them to make sheep pastures.
This was done by landlords who were short of tenants.
They found that doing that was a good way of keeping their land in production,
although a low intensity production when otherwise it might go vacant or might
be unprofitable.
Wool was in demand for the cloth industry,
so they went over to a kind of sheep ranching at the time that wasn't
particularly controversial,
but after the 1510s steps to end close land,
which had formerly been open,
became much more controversial,
uh,
in the Midlands,
which was a major wolf supplying area,
many landlords withdrew land from the plow to turn it into sheep ranches.
Despite the growing demand from tenants for land,
some landlords also took in and then closed for their own use land,
which had formerly been the common pasture land of particular villages.
Thereby they reduced the area of common pasture available to their tenants,
which was a further grievance,
especially since common land was particularly valuable in conditions of land
hunger.
While these changing conditions meant that and closure,
which had previously been merely a tactic you could adopt on your estate,
became a quite significant grievance in many areas of the kingdom.
It seemed to many people a very visible sign of the changing balance of power in
rural society between Lords and tenants.
So Thomas Moore in his utopia refers to the phenomenon of sheep eating men in
England.
At this time reflecting that sense of grievance.
It's for these reasons that issues of rents and fines and customs and common
land became a quite explosive cocktail in London,
landlord tenant relations by the mid 16th century
and there was also a little more to it than that.
The economic trends and the population trends of the period with gradually
producing a greater differentiation in village society amongst tenants.
There were those who did quite well in these circumstances,
especially the bigger farmers,
the yeomanry quite often they held part of their land in freehold.
They were somewhat protected.
Quite often.
They produced a large surplus which they could market and if prices were rising,
they could make bigger profits.
They were able to pay higher rents without too much trouble.
They might take on more land to extend their operations and if they wanted to do
that,
they were in a far better position to compete for available land than where
their poorer neighbors.
So this is a period when one sees the yeomanry becoming increasingly
differentiated in their wealth and living standards from the poorer neighbors.
These were people who were able to benefit from the trends of the period.
They showed a lot of ambition in the way they did that and the ambition of those
who are best able to take advantage of the trends of the this generation.
That ambition is also shown in response to another economic development of the
period and this time it's an economic development which wasn't directly
connected to population or price trends,
but was connected to the religious changes and I'm thinking of course,
of the dissolution of the monasteries and bringing onto the market of vast
quantities of former monastic land.
Okay.
Some figures relating to this are there on your handout in section three,
basically between 1536 and 1540 about 60% of the land,
which was owned by the church,
was transferred to the crown through the dissolution of the monasteries.
Many studies have been done of individual counties and the county of Essex down
here to the east of London,
for example,
the Church had owned about 28% of the manners in that county by 1540 after the
dissolution,
it owned only 2%.
It's a massive transfer of land.
Well,
these seizures of church land we'll probably intended by Thomas Cromwell to
endow the crown in perpetuity with massive land holdings,
which would render it absolutely unchallengeable and indeed it might even render
it independent of any grants of taxation from parliament.
But if that was Cromwells intention,
it failed to materialize because most of the monastic land was quite rapidly
disposed off by the crown.
By the time Henry the eighth himself died in 1547 he had already sold something
like two thirds of the monastery land,
which had come into him and still more of this land was sold later.
Um,
for example,
there's been a study done of the of the whole of Wales,
which shows that of the monastic land there,
60% had gone by the death of Henry in 1547 and by the time Elizabeth to the
throne in 1558,
75% of the monastery land had been disposed off.
Why would the crown dispose of the land in this kind of way?
Well basically to pay for wars,
wars,
which were getting more expensive,
requiring fortresses,
modern weapons,
new ships and so forth.
Henry the eighth in his last year,
engaged in short,
inconclusive,
utterly,
utterly futile.
Um,
assertions of his rights as he sold them against France and against Scotland
resulting in wars and massive expenditure which are counted for much of the
monastic land.
For our purposes today,
it's interesting to note the results of studies which have looked at the
identities of who's buying this land from the crown
quite a lot when to the heads of established noble and gentry families,
people who are anxious to take advantage of this wonderful opportunity to
consolidate their estates,
to rationalize the estates and so forth,
to build up their holdings in particular areas of their strength.
Another group who emerged quite strongly are people who are the youngest sons of
such gentry and noble families.
People who are in the normal course of events would expect most of the family's
property to pass to their older brothers,
but who now had an opportunity to get in and get some land for themselves.
Younger brothers,
they could set up cadet branches of the family and sometimes they did so with
the money which they had generated in trade or in professionals.
Younger sons were often put into trade or into professions and we're able to
make the money which enabled them to return to Landon society and set themselves
up as minor gentleman.
Okay.
Another significant group were upwardly mobile people from the middle ranks of
society,
Yeoman farmers piecing together field to field until they could emerge with a
sufficient to state to call themselves gentlemen,
people from the towns who had no gentry ancestry,
perhaps lawyers,
perhaps actions,
prosperous craftsmen and tradesmen who were able to acquire land and it's
superior social status perhaps in some cases on a level which would again bring
them into the lower ranks of the gentry.
So they were customers enough for this monastic land and to serve their needs.
There were many speculators.
A lot of the monastic land was bought by speculators who rapidly sold it on
the overall effects of this was a kind of feeding frenzy in the landmark it.
It resulted,
of course not only in this severe reduction of the position of the church as a
great landowner,
but it also resulted ultimately in a very significant rise in both the numbers
of those who called themselves gentlemen and in the relative wealth of the
Gentry as a whole.
So some people who were doing very well out of all of this,
but of course it's not all buoyancy,
no process of change of this kind ever is,
and so one has to ask who are the losers in these processes and there are some
large and quite obvious groups amongst the losers.
We're a small farm tenants who couldn't easily meet rising rents,
who didn't sell enough on the market to produce the profits,
which would pay them,
who were finding it difficult to make ends meet.
Then there were those who were one could think of is would be farm tenants.
Those who might aspire to getting a foothold on the land,
but found it increasingly difficult because rents were rising,
fines were rising and so forth,
and they couldn't compete with the bigger guys in the village who could take up
land that came available on the local market.
It could be quite a difficult time for the young in that respect,
but above all,
there were the growing numbers of landless people in the countryside or in the
towns whose living dependent principally on what they could earn from wage
earning as laborers and the rights to use Commons,
which they might enjoy in the places where they live.
Those who dependent on wages were particularly hard hit by inflation and despite
the fact that prices were rising,
squeezing their living standards,
wages rose only slowly because the population was growing and there was plenty
of labor available.
Wages tended to remain pretty sticky at customary levels for long periods of
time.
That meant that people's real wages,
the real purchasing power of their wages was falling.
Some quite close studies of this had been done and they suggest that between 15,
10 and 1550 the purchasing power of wages fell by about 40% in the south of
England.
By the 1550s they were down 50% and they began to recover modestly only in the
latest 16th century.
So these were quite hard times for a lot of people.
Um,
William Harrison,
who wrote a famous description of England at the beginning of the reign of
Elizabeth,
described how many of what he described as the inferior sot of people lived
principally on what he called white meats,
eggs and cheese and bread
in times dearth.
They were particularly hard hit and might have to live on peas and beans or even
ground acorns,
which they tried to bake into bread.
He added,
I will not say that this extremity is often also found in times of plenty,
but if I should,
I could easily stand my trial.
And that's Harrison's ironic comment on the living standards of the poor in his
time.
Well,
all of this was reflected in a growing contemporary concern with the problem of
poverty.
There had always been poor of course,
but poverty as a major social problem hadn't been a major issue in the 15th
century.
It was more a matter of the poverty that resulted from lifecycle crises of a
small minority of people.
The widowed,
the aged,
the sick orphan children.
These were the ones that contemporary is referred to as the impotent poor.
Those who could not help themselves,
those who are poor by circumstances beyond their control.
But as the 16th century advanced people began talking and writing about poverty
into worryingly expanded forms,
they first became aware of the problem of vagrancy,
the problem of what they called rogues and vagabonds
homeless people visible on the streets of the towns or on the roads of the
countryside.
People like one man who was arrested by the justices of the peace over near the
Welsh border,
uh,
who in the examination,
which they took from him,
told them that he was a person who dwells,
no,
I'm quoting the examination.
He dwells nowhere,
nor has no abiding,
but where he might find work.
The vagrant looking for work moving around the countryside.
People like this.
We're a much more common site as the 16th century advanced.
It's quite interesting that in his translation of the New Testament,
William Tyndall,
in trying to describe a scene from the acts of the apostles where Saint Paul is
attacked by a mob in Thessalonica,
uh,
translated the Greek word,
which literally means people standing in the street.
He translated it as vagabonds.
When Tyndall tried to imagine people hanging around in the street,
he imagined them as somebody vagrants who he would have seen on the streets of
London.
So vagrancy,
rogues,
and vagabonds or emerging as a significant problem.
On the other hand,
there was the growing problem of what they described as the laboring poor people
whose whole style of life was based increasingly on a kind of economy of
makeshifts getting work wherever they could working,
certainly,
but finding it increasingly difficult to make ends meet the laboring poor people
who would also fall into really severe poverty if they suffered any misfortune,
if they couldn't find work,
if there was a depression in the cloth industry,
if they felt sick and so forth.
These people were especially visible in areas where wage workers were
concentrated,
principally the towns or those areas of the countryside where many people worked
in rural industries.
Okay.
Then that,
let's just take stock
by the 1540s rising prices and demographic growth had seen in some ways a
quickening of economic activity.
For some people,
this brought new opportunities and indeed enhanced prosperity,
but at the same time there was also a growing sense of tension in the
relationships between landlords and their peasant tenants and an emerging
problem of land hunger,
a growing problem of a wage labor in population which was very vulnerable to
poverty on an unaccustomed scale.
Our people were aware of these changes.
They were aware of the tensions,
but from their perspective at the time it was the symptoms of change which were
more apparent than the actual causes.
It,
it was exceedingly difficult for people in the 16th century to comprehend what
was happening to them.
They didn't keep official statistics.
The figures which are on your handout,
I've been calculated by historians using a variety of sources.
Contemporaries didn't have information of this kind.
They tended to perceive changes and emergent problems of this kind through their
inherited attitudes.
They're essentially medieval moral philosophy,
a view of the world in which economic behavior wasn't treated as a distinct area
of activity,
a phenomenon to be studied in itself by the science of economics.
They saw it as a branch of personal and social morality.
The ideal world,
in their view,
was the world of the Commonwealth,
which I've described to you.
They saw these problems as failings in the ideal of the Commonwealth failings,
which could be attributed to the misdeeds of specific people.
Well,
these ideas not only persisted throughout the early 16th century,
but they were powerfully reemphasized in the 1540s with the emergence of a group
of moralists,
most of them Protestant clergymen in the reign of Edward the sixth who addressed
these social and economic grievances.
They were known at the time as the Commonwealth's men,
because they talked constantly about the needs of the Commonwealth.
Such people also saw the reformation,
not simply in terms of the jurisdictional independence of the Church of England
from the Church of Rome,
or simply in terms of fundamental doc trinal changes.
They also thought it was an opportunity for the re moralizing of society,
the revitalization of Christian values in society.
They advocated an ideal Christian Commonwealth.
They thought this was the opportunity to achieve it,
and yet they saw all around them evidence of the corruption of social
relationships by what they saw as the cardinal sin of covetousness.
One of their favorite words,
covetousness,
greed,
and the punishes idea again,
which they constantly refer to that quote every man may do with his own as he
will,
the notion that every man may do with his own as he will,
which they regarded as an unchristian attitude
in their view.
Worldly goods were given by God to be handled with stewardship,
with an interest to society as a whole.
So there are social vision was essentially conservative.
They saw a change in terms of social dislocation and moral corruption.
They denounced the representatives of covetousness,
whom they identified.
They spoke,
for example of and gentle gentlemen.
They attacked what they call the caterpillars of the Commonwealth eating up it's
green shoots.
They attach what they saw as exploitation and oppression of the poor,
and they did all of this in a language reminiscent of Old Testament prophets.
Um,
rh Tawney greatest story in of these changes.
It says they used the moral rhetoric in his words of an age that had
rediscovered the Bible.
Well,
it hadn't rediscovered it.
It had discovered it for the first time in English.
And as I said,
the language of Jeremiah or Isaiah is the kind of language that they used to
denounce
what they saw as a world out of joint.
Well,
the pamphlets written by these people in the 1540s and 1550s are quite
magnificent literature of moral indignation.
It still has the capacity to thrill when you read it.
It indicated also what's been described by one recent historian as a crisis of
legitimation crisis of legitimation.
The world seemed out of joint in so many ways,
but response to change also took a more direct form.
There were not only those who were appealing for reform,
for moral reformation,
for people to behave as they should.
They were also those who were prepared to directly resist these changes,
especially in the countryside.
A,
from about the 1530s onwards,
um,
researchers working on records of local government and on the courts find that
the country was increasingly pockmarked with minor forms of disorder as the
peasantry of particular localities really resisted initiatives on the part of
their landlords,
perhaps rioting against the enclosing the fields or of common land and so forth.
Oregon's changes in their customs and 10 years and such resistance becomes above
all evident in some of the great risings of the Commons,
which took place in the middle third of the 16th century risings,
which convulsed first the north of England and then the east of England in
particular.
The first of these risings was the pilgrimage of grace of 1536 arising of much
of the north of England.
This was a complex event.
It combined religious hostility to the reformation and a desire to defend the
monasteries,
which had been ordered to be dissolved with a variety of other grievances.
And in particular agrarian grievances against the enclosing of Commons and the
forcing up of entry fines to land.
It was described by those who took part in it as a pilgrimage of grace for the
Commonwealth,
for the Commonwealth as a whole.
And those who mustard for the pilgrimage.
Some 20,000 men,
um,
regarded themselves as defending each branch of the Commonwealth.
They wanted the king to turn away from his evil counselors.
They wanted the ancient rites as an ability to be properly recognized.
They wanted the rights of the church to be respected.
And as they put in one of their statements of grievances,
they also demanded that the commonalty be used as they should be.
The commonalty be used as they should be,
particularly in matters relating to the land.
So this was a complex event.
It led to the rebel army eventually mustering near Pontefract in South
Yorkshire,
having taken the city of York where it faced a standoff with royal troops under
the Duke of Norfolk.
The Duke negotiated with the rebels,
persuaded those gentlemen who had joined them in particular to act as our
negotiators with the crown promise that their grievances would be met and
persuaded them to disperse.
The rebels were wrong to trust.
Um,
Norfolk,
he was already writing to the crown that he regarded no promises made to a rebel
as binding.
And when the crown got the opportunity with the flurry of a few more agrarian
troubles in the northwest,
at the beginning of the following year,
royal troops went in and suppress them with considerable violence.
Robert ask the leader of the rebels who was a lawyer from York,
um,
along with a number of other figures,
was arrested,
tried and executed for treason.
That was the pilgrimage of grace.
Probably the biggest threat that the tutor Monica ever faced.
Then in 1549 came another widespread burst of unrest known as the camping time
because many tenants from particular areas we're gathering together in protest
and forming camps.
Uh,
these were scattered all over central eastern and southern England.
Many of these camps where ultimately dispersed,
um,
the Earl of Arundel in Sussex for example,
down towards the south coast met the,
um,
protesting peasants assured them that he would speak for them on their behalf
and persuaded them to disperse.
This was the way that it could sometimes be handled.
And Aaron [inaudible],
Aaron dealt,
kept his word.
He did speak for them,
but one particular rising did not disperse.
And that was the one in the county of Norfolk,
led by Robert Cat,
a yeoman farmer,
cats,
rebels,
advanced to set up a camp just outside knowledge.
Um,
on most hold heath outside knowledge where cats who was very well organized,
had a supply system to keep the,
the,
the uh,
to keep his army as it was.
By then a well supplied a,
he sat under an oak tree on the heath,
which was known as the OIC of reformation.
And there with his counsel,
he delivered justice,
uh,
to the local farm tenants against their gentlemen,
landlords,
the principal grievances of the Norfolk rising where agrarian,
they were protesting against enhanced rents and against the abuses of common
land by their landlords.
And their also remarkable in the cat's rebels refused to disperse.
Eventually a royal army was sent against them.
It consisted mostly of mercenaries who had been hired from Germany and Italy.
Um,
they didn't dare use English troops for fear.
They would sympathize with the rebels.
A cat's army refused to disperse and went down fighting in a battle at Dustin
Dale just outside the city of knowledge.
It's been said of these peasant rebels that they were trying to create a world
in which gentleman were kept at arm's length.
They were trying to preserve the rights that they had in the land,
in a changing economic climate,
which threatened to diminish them trying to create a world in which gentlemen
were kept at arm's length and their statements of grievances.
And demands make very interesting reading.
Uh,
there's a rich literature on these rebellions.
If anyone's interested in that for an essay topic,
I'd be happy to advise you.
So in seeking to restore what was essentially an idealized vision of stable
social relationships,
the just Commonwealth,
an ideal which they located in a past golden age,
both the peasant rebels and the literary Commonwealth men,
the preachers and clergy had a great deal in common.
And together they give perhaps the most vivid expression,
literary expression and practical expression to the sense that many people had
in the mid 16th century that the bonds of society,
the bonds of Commonwealth were fraying and falling apart.
But neither the Commonwealth's men in their books and sermons nor the peasant
grapples could turn back the dynamic of change,
moral exhortation or localized protest by people who couldn't face a royal army.
Effectively,
we're not enough.
And both were swept aside after 1549.
It's one of the nice ironies of history that the place outside Norridge now in
the suburbs,
uh,
where cats rebels were finally defeated,
very bloodily,
many were slotted.
Um,
uh,
Dustin Dale is now the site of a shopping mall.
So the English peasant who made their last stand there and it's now a shopping
mall.
There's sort of shrine to modern consumerism.
Um,
amongst the murals are decorated.
There's one of Robert Cat sitting under the tree of reformation,
which I hope schoolchildren in Norridge will or recognize as they go about their
shopping,
but it wasn't all repression.
There's another side to the story.
By 1549 some people in positions of authority in the kingdom.
We're equally concerned about all of this
and they were trying to come to grips with changing an alternative way.
A striking piece of evidence of this is a wonderful composition written for
circulation in manuscript in 1549 by Sir Thomas Smith and entitled the discourse
of the Commonweal of England.
It's a remarkable piece of writing.
It wasn't published until after Smith's death and at one time it was actually
attributed to William Shakespeare,
but it's now pretty certain that it was written by Sir Thomas Smith.
He was professor of civil law at the University of Cambridge and a leading
member later in his career of the Royal Privy Council under Edward the sixth and
subsequently under Elizabeth.
The first
Smith was trying to think out the problems of his day,
not to denounce the moral failings of particular individuals or groups,
but to try to understand what was going on,
to try to understand the motives and the pressures that were felt by different
people in society.
And he did that by having a discussion.
He wrote a dialogue between a gentleman husbandman,
a peasant,
a craftsman,
a wage worker,
and I figure called the doctor who was a sort of academic figure who acts as a
kind of moderator for this discussion.
He imagines them all sitting outside a pub discussing the affairs of the
Commonwealth.
It's because it was dialogue form that it was once attributed to Shakespeare.
The representatives of the different groups in the discourse of the common wheel
put their own perspectives,
their own grievances,
the different voices of different interest groups are heard.
The doctor who acts as moderator,
provides a kind of disinterested,
analytical authority helping to explore the underlying causes to propose
solutions to think of ways that the interests of different groups might be
reconciled.
So for example,
when the view is put by the gentlemen that all men are free to make their most
advantage of that,
which is their own,
the phrase or close to the phrase,
which was always being denounced by the Commonwealth men Smith has the doctor
reply not by denouncing covetousness,
but by saying yes they may,
but they may not use their own to the damage of the common Commonweal.
Good Lord should set limits to the pursuit of individual economic interest.
In short,
then he's willing to accept the simple reality of self interested behavior,
but he seeks to prevent abuses or to channel that behavior in ways that it might
serve the common interest through the encouragement of enterprise.
It's because of that kind of attitude that Smith has been described as the
father of political economy and does some justice in that,
but essentially putting him in his own time.
He was in the classical humanist tradition.
He had great faith in the positive effects of good government as a means of
harmonizing conflicting interests and that's what he's trying essentially to
achieve.
Well.
So Thomas Smith wasn't alone and he had considerable influence upon likeminded
statesman under Edward the sixth and still more in the early years of Elizabeth.
The first he sat himself in Elizabeth's council,
he was responsible for drafting some of the early legislation of her
parliaments.
He was a very close friend of her chief advisor,
so William sessile
and it led this kind of attitude among Smith and others to a kind of dual
strategy on the part of government which has gradually emerging in the mid 16th
century.
On the one hand they want to stabilize things,
they want to dampen things down,
they want to remit the fraying fabric of the Commonwealth.
On the other hand,
they were very aware of the need to pursue where possible orderly economic
growth
and this is used in a number of statutes which are listed in the last part of
your handout and which I'll just briefly mention,
which were intended to be steps towards these ends.
In 1551 the coinage was revalued and reissued in an attempt to curb the worst
excesses of inflation.
In 1552 legislation was passed against abuses in marketing again with a view to
the problems occasioned by the price rise.
In the 1550s the royal courts were made more open to hear the grievances of the
peasantry,
some of whom had not previously been able to plead in royal courts.
In 1563 we're now under the reign of Elizabeth.
The statute of artifices was past the longest single act of parliament passed in
England before the 20th century,
which went into great detail in attempts to regulate relationships between
employers and employees to lay down rules to introduce,
for example,
annual assessments of wages so that wages could be adjusted in line with prices.
In 1563 legislation was passed to restrict not all forms of enclosure,
but those forms of enclosure,
which were thought to be harmful.
If enclosure was beneficial,
it would be permitted.
And in addition,
they introduced on the model of experiments which had been attempted in a number
of towns,
forms of relief for the impotent poor,
a constructive system of poor relief,
which was to operate at the level of the parish involving the raising of money
from local taxation of those who could afford it,
the poor rate and the dispersal of that money to the impotent pool.
Finally,
efforts were made to encourage economically enterprising people who brought
projects to the government,
establishment of new trade routes,
the encouragement of shipping and fishing,
the establishment of new manufacturing industries,
which might be granted a royal patrons giving them a monopoly until they were
established.
So the origins and the patent system,
the encouragement of immigration,
of skilled Protestant refugees from abroad,
especially from the Netherlands where the religious wars were raging.
So one mustn't exaggerate the impact of all of this.
This is a 16th century.
Their powers of enforcement,
we're limited,
but efforts were being made very visible efforts to do something about the
situation.
And that marked a significant step forward in the conception of the
responsibilities of the tutors state,
a broadening of its role and increasing presence in attempting to shape to
channel the economic and social developments of the time to develop policy,
to deal with the problems that they produced.
And that helped shape the environment of change as people gradually moved from
the first shocks of response to these changing features of the economic and
social environment and began to enter a period of transition in the late 16th
century towards a more thoroughly commercial economy,
which is something I'll touch on later.
But for now,
we need to turn back again.
Having looked at what was happening in the mid 16th century outside the
religious sphere to the issues of the reformation and the settlement,
which was attempted with the succession in 1558 of Elizabeth,
and we'll take that up on Tuesday.